[Music]
easy was the only one invited to the
Australian set up thor ragnarok and that
is square camera medicine got all the
behind-the-scenes scoop starting with
doors main makeover
Thor gets a little bit of a haircut it
sounds good a haircut how does that how
does that come about like I mean you
know get makeover gone I don't want to
weigh the wasted hours to put on kind of
just run with a creative license fair
yeah on set there's a lot of flying
wires for Chris plenty of fight moves
one just as strong look-alike stunt
double and thousands of Australian fans
waiting for the chance to meet the god
of thunder yeah but Tom and I spend a
lot of time sort of you know in between
takes coming out and trying to sign
autographs and take photos like hundreds
hundreds of self yeah very good at the
one-handed selfie might kind of a few
steps ahead of me kind of getting the
cameras ready and handing him to me
four months of shooting took place all
over Australia from the Gold Coast
2:36 giant sound stages in Queensland
come on this is amazing right this is
the set of a scart the whole thing is
the size of an American football field
to 450 construction workers four months
to build this amazing set welcome to ask
God now this is the chair that imprisons
Thor
oh yeah now the multiple four hammers
onset but there is only one hero hammer
this is it and it's got some good weight
to it I guess about twenty to
twenty-five pounds
we know each other he's a friend from
work
but this epic battle between Thor and
Hulk is what Chris was looking forward
to the most before we did written in the
script it was like we want to sort of
Center it around this and I thought well
that's I mean you know I was like oh
well what else can we throw in and what
can we do that we haven't done before
it's almost like your own version of
Civil War show up here in space yeah
we're gonna go hit the gym right now I
am I'll be in there like lifting these
look like dinky way it's nice to like
Thor
[Music]
you